[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je suis venu
vous parler de changement je suis venu
vous parler plus particulièrement de la
capacité que l'on a
nous en tant qu'humain de change et la
capacité que l'on a à titre individuel à
titre collectif de changer mais avant
d'aborder la question du changement
j'aimerais concentre bien dans cette
idée que nous humains font des
collectifs des collectivités et pour
cela j'aimerais faire un petit exercice
avec vous j'aimerais que chacun de vous
se représente le réseau social dans
lequel il est inclus j'aimerais que
chacun de vous essai de visualiser la
place qu'il a dans ce collectif
alors on va y aller ensemble vous
demandez peut-être de fermer vos yeux on
va ou plutôt ouvrez les imaginait sur
cette salle les gens qui vous entourent
ceux avec qui vous avez des interactions
fréquentes
commençons par votre famille ceux avec
qui vous avez vécu la famille que vous
voyez peut-être un peu moins souvent
durant l'année est ce que vous voyez de
manière ponctuelle plaçons les lun
maintenant imaginez vous représentez
vous sur cette scène vos amis vos amis
très proches puis vos groupes d'amis
avec qui vous sortez avec qui vous
traîner avec nous partager ces moments
puis les amis que vous voyez toujours
mais un peu moins fréquemment
maintenant imaginez vous ici les
personnes avec qui vous travaillez votre
réseau professionnel
imaginez vous vos collègues vos
collaborateurs
les personnes qui font partie de retirer
ou si vous êtes dans une école imaginez
vous vos camarades de classe vos
professeurs et finalement sur cette
scène s'il reste de la place
imaginez-vous ceux avec qui vous faites
du sport avec qui vous faites partie
d'associations avec qui vous habitez ou
voisins les personnes que vous croisez
dans votre quartier dans votre ville à
ce moment là la scène pour chacun de
vous doit être assez remplie
parce que à chaque pour chaque personne
pour chaque individu nous avons à peu
près une centaine de personnes avec qui
nous interagissons de manière fréquente
maintenant essayer pendant un court
instant d'imaginer que chacune de ces
personnes a elle-même un réseau social
elle même inclus dans un collectif au
mieux pour vous qui êtes dans cette
salle
imaginez que pour chacun de vous chacun
de vous et est capable de remplir cette
scène de personnes qu'ils
interagissaient et ensemble nous formons
une collectivité nous faisons société
seulement la société que nous formons
dans sa conformation actuelle est bien
le n'est pas durable elle n'est pas
soutenable
elle n'est pas soutenable et c'est un
fait c'est un fait ou en tout cas c'est
une collection de fait les faisceau de
preuves qui pointent dans cette
direction le premier c'est le
réchauffement climatique
nous sommes extrêmement dépendant des
énergies fossiles
nous consommons énormément d'énergie et
ses énergies fossiles et bien et met
énormément de gaz à effet de serre de
carbone dans l'atmosphère ce qui
provoque un réchauffement notre planète
un dérèglement notre climat et un
changement abrupt et rapide jamais
observé nos conditions de vie
ensuite en tant que société nous avons
un impact direct sur notre environnement
parce que nos modes de production de
consommation d'agriculture et bien
impacte directement la biodiversité nos
écosystèmes
ces espèces qu'on voyait derrière moins
bien souvent d'envoi disparition en
france comme une centaine d'autres est
actuellement en france 30% des oiseaux
ont déjà disparu
en trente ans les scientifiques parlent
de sixième extinction de masse et
finalement autant que société bien nous
rejetons énormément de choses dans notre
environnement
la pollution de l'air cause cinquante
mille morts en france par an la
pollution des terres mais aussi des
océans bientôt le plastique remplacera
les poissons et les microparticules de
plastique sont en train de se loger dans
chaque organisme et remonte notre chaîne
alimentaire jusqu'à nos assiettes
tout ça nous le savons où nous sommes
peut-être pas conscients de tout mais en
tout cas nous savons que nos sociétés
actuellement n'est pas soutenable et que
nous devons changer nouveau changé de
conformation seulement nous ne changeons
pas et la question c'est pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne change pas les sciences du
comportement ou plus précisément les
sciences cognitives qui essaie de
décrypter l'esprit humain
et les comportements qu'il produit ce
milieu de recherche dans lequel j'évolue
et bien propose des clés de lecture ou
ont identifié certains obstacles ou
certains freins au changement individuel
le premier c'est notre perception nous
percevons le monde à travers nos sens
nous percevons le monde d'une manière
immédiate et des dérèglements comme le
réchauffement climatique
des problèmes qui sont aussi d'aussi
grande ampleur que la chute de la
biodiversité sont souvent invisibles et
bien nous sont imperceptibles ne voyons
pas au quotidien
la température augmente et nous voulions
pas au quotidien les eaux monter un
deuxième frein obstacle au changement
ce sont nos préférences nous avons des
préférences qui sont orientés vers le
court terme les préférences qui sont
dirigés par nos petits plaisirs du
quotidien par un confort que l'on veut
maximiser et même si nous savons que nos
régimes alimentaires sont mauvais pour
notre santé sont mauvais pour
l'environnement
eh bien nous avons énormément de mal à
l'échangé et la tentation est souvent
trop grande et quand nous y arrivons et
bien nos habitudes nous freine
nous sommes des individus d être pétri
l'automatisme et la plupart de ses
automatismes régissent nos vies à tel
point que même pour les fumeurs qui
savent que de jeter un mégot dans le
caniveau pollue des mètres cubes d'eau
et bien souvent par réflexe le font
quand même
et finalement notre environnement
physique dans lequel nous évoluons et
bien nous contraint il contraint nos
choix
il diminue les alternatives possibles
essayer de faire vos courses et de
ressortir du supermarché sans emballage
plastique
c'est un défi donc finalement nous avons
tout un tas de frein ou d'obstacles en
tant qu'individu à ce changement
parlons parfois de biais cognitifs vous
avez peut-être entendu parler moi c'est
mon métier d'essayer de comprendre
d'identifier ces obstacles ses freins
pour aider les citoyens les
collectivités les décideurs à essayer de
passer de l'intention à l'action
mais aujourd'hui je voudrais que l'on
s'attarde sur une question qui est
derrière tout ça et la question c'est
peut-on changer
est-on capable de changer en tant
qu'humain suffisamment pour pouvoir
affronter la crise climatique pour
pouvoir lutter contre la chute de
biodiversité pour changer à l'échelle de
la société
eh bien je vais vous proposer de changer
maintenant de perspectives et d'essayer
de regarder de nous regarder en tant
qu'humain en tant qu'espèce pour
l'animal que nous sommes et c'est de
nous regarder à travers le regard des
sciences du comportement des regarde des
sciences cognitives et si on adopte
cette ce regard à la si on essaie de
prendre du recul sur nous mêmes en tant
qu'homo sapiens et bien voilà ce qu on
pourrait observer ceux ci et
l'environnement dans laquelle nous
évoluons il ya une centaine de milliers
d'années enfin plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'années
à cette époque si nos ancêtres les homo
sapiens vivait en tribu vivait en petits
groupes
chassez cueillez il ya trois cent mille
ans environ nous sommes déployés à
travers l'afrique et nous avons commencé
il ya une dizaines de milliers d'années
à réussir à stocker de la nourriture à
gérer notre nourriture grâce à la
révolution de l'agriculture et puis
petit à petit nous avons nous sommes
déployés sur tous les continents de
tribu nous sommes passés à royaume puis
à empire jusqu'à aujourd'hui
ou plutôt il ya quelques centaines
d'années où nous avons fait émerger de
sol du solde evil devil complexe des
villes dans lesquelles la plupart faire
la moitié de la population humaine vit
désormais nous vivons dans un
environnement urbain nous avons
construit les systèmes de transport les
systèmes d'organisation et au delà de la
révolution industrielle qui nous a
permis de nous a conduits à cela et bien
nous avons eu des révolutions
technologiques mais également des
révolutions de communication
actuellement la moitié de l'humanité
connecté à internet
ce que je dis vous pouvez l'écrire sur
le téléphone le tweet elle envoyait à
votre communauté à votre réseau social
afin de le partager
mais le plus impressionnant là dedans
c'est que nous avons gardé fonds d'un
homme fondamentalement le même cerveau
c'est-à-dire que le cerveau que nous
avons maintenant c'est à peu près le
même que nos ancêtres il ya plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'années et avec le
même cerveau nous avons été capables
d'opérer les changements majeurs
nous sommes passés de chasseurs
cueilleurs a serial twitter donc ça
voudrait dire que dans notre cerveau en
nous ils viennent qu'à passer de
changement qui est extraordinaire nous
serions capables de changer de s'adapter
pour passer d'un moment à l'autre et
c'est ce que l'on va essayer d'explorer
tout de suite si on reprend les freins
que nous avons
identifier jusqu alors les freins dans
notre quotidien au changement eh bien
ces freins là sont en fait des facettes
extraordinaire de notre commission
prenons la perception nous sommes
capables à travers nos sens de percevoir
le monde dans toute sa complexité
et ce dans l'instant sommes capables de
sentir des milliards d'odeurs à la fois
et on peut aller plus loin si vous
regardez ces images vous pouvez estimer
quand est ce qu elles sont été prises en
quelle saison
vous pouvez également peut-être
identifiés ou est-ce qu'elles ont été
prises en france
et si vous les regardez un peu plus
longuement peut-être que des souvenirs
vont émerger
peut-être que votre mémoire va
travailler va projeter sur ces images
des souvenirs de ski des souvenirs de
vacances et souvenirs d'été et bientôt
et bien vos représentations vont se
détacher la réalité devant vos yeux vont
se jouer des scènes qui sont ne sont pas
visibles directement et c'est ce que
nous avons fait dans l'exercice de
départ vous avez projeter sur cette
scène les personnes avec qui vous
interagissez fréquemment ces personnes
n'étaient pas là nous avait projeté de
kbc de perception de représentation du
monde sont extrêmement développé nos
préférences et bien nous sommes capables
de changer de régime alimentaire
bien sûr au prix d'énormes efforts mais
nous pouvons essayer de faire du sport
pour perdre du poids vous vous changez
nos préférences et quand nous n'y
arrivons pas à cause de nos habitudes et
bien ses habitudes là c'est le témoin
d'une capacité extrêmement forte que
nous avons d'automatiser nos
comportements nous sommes capables pour
les actions qui sont les plus
répétitives qui sont peut-être les moins
pertinentes de les automatiser ne vais
rendre inconscientes et d'automatiser
certaines de nos actions nous permet
d'être multi tâches si je fume une
cigarette devant un restaurant
eh bien je pourrais en même temps parler
à une personne en face de moi peut être
regarder si j'ai ma carte bleue dans la
poche et peut-être même regarder si dans
le restaurant on est en train de me
servir mon plein donc ses capacités
d'automatisation ses habitudes nous
permettent de faire plusieurs choses à
la fois et finalement notre
environnement
eh bien nous avons fait sortir de terre
ses supermarchés
nous avons créé des espaces où nous
pouvons en se déplaçant une fois pouvoir
répondre à nos besoins et donc nous
avons une capacité de pouvoir façonner
le monde pour qu'il réponde à ce dont
nous avons besoin
donc vous voyez que là derrière ce
qu'ils étaient avant des freins sont en
fait des capacités qui sont assez
extraordinaire mais en tant qu'humain
nous avons une capacité supplémentaire
qui est notre vie
sial cette vie sociale elle est
transversal à les transversales parce
qu'elle nous permet de pouvoir booster
nos capacités cognitives
elle nous permet de nous dépasser nous
même de dépasser nos propres limites
par exemple la perception et bien on ne
voit toujours pas réchauffement
climatique
on ne voit toujours pas la chute de la
biodiversité mais des scientifiques ont
travaillé pendant des années se sont
regroupés enfants ont formé des
connaissances et ses connaissances qui
sont issus du groupe de travail du giec
et bien nous paraître maintenant de
pouvoir nous en équipe et pour
représenter ces changements au quotidien
nous utilisons les autres en tout cas
les autres nous permettent de pouvoir
enrichir notre vision mais j'aime et et
aux maldives et pourtant je sais à quoi
cela ressemble
j'ai entendu parler de différentes
différents retours et j'ai vu des photos
pareil pour nos préférences les eaux
sont impuissants motivateur par exemple
je ne fais pas du sport pour perdre du
poids simplement pour moi je le fais
peut-être pour plaire aux autres je le
fais parce que j'ai envie de renvoyer
une image saine ou positive aux autres
un certain certains de nos goûts
certains de notre vision d'esthétisme
sont influencés par les autres nos
habitudes et bien sujet de mon mégot par
terre et que les personnes qui sont
autour de moi me juge pour ceux - regard
sévère et bien très vite je vais essayer
de changer mon comportement pour ne
garder inclus dans ce groupe là est
d'ailleurs de normes sociales sont des
automatismes
c'est une manière d'automatiser nos
comportements pour pouvoir réguler notre
vie en communauté et finalement notre
environnement et bien je ne suis un cas
pas moins tout seul de faire un
supermarché
l.sane nécessite une coordination et
d'organisation pour des moyens de
production d'acheminement de stockage de
vente et c'est donc notre vie sociale
nous permet de nous dépasser nous mêmes
et en fait elle est essentielle elle est
essentielle parce que si nous sommes
isolés d'un groupe social et bien nous
allons tomber dans la dépression sommes
capables de faire des bras et des jambes
pour rester inclus dans le groupe auquel
on appartient ou même de se faire
inclure ou de se sentir accepté par un
groupe que nous valorisons cette vie
sociale est essentielle parce que la
solitude l'isolément et bien tu sous
certains
sur certains critères autant que le
tabagisme cette vie sociale est
essentielle parce que le stress social
et je peux vous en parler est un des
plus puissants stress que nous pouvons
expérience donc vous pouvons faire
l'expérience en tant qu'humain c'est vie
sociale est essentielle parce qu'elle
nous permet à nous dépasser et que c'est
cette hyper sociabilité qui permet à
nous humains d'avoir cette capacité dix
paires adaptabilité et cette hyper
sociabilité nous pouvons identifier
trois piliers qui la composent le
premier c'est que en tant qu'espèce nous
sommes capables de générer de partager
les connaissances pour voir au loin
parce que nous sommes assis sur les
épaules d'un géant comme pour
paraphraser newton newton qui a fait
connaître cette cette phrase nous
partageons des connaissances ensemble et
ensuite nous sommes capables de coopérer
dans un but commun de dépasser notre
intelligence individuelles et de faire
preuve d'intelligence collective et
cette coopération
eh bien nous pouvons encore plus
optimisée en faisant preuve
d'organisation en mettant à profit nos
différences nos particularités en
mettant à profit nos expertises pour
pouvoir justement augmenter notre
capacité de changement et cette
organisation et 7 capes et c'est de
changement se fait à différents niveaux
le foyer niveau nous l'avons vu c'est
qu'en tant qu'individu et bien on peut
on peut s'adapter on peut réutiliser des
outils on peut apprendre peut réduire sa
consommation
on peut donner de son temps de son
argent nous pouvons ensuite nous
organiser en groupe en collectif en
réseau pour pouvoir essayer de se
convaincre mutuellement ou les autres se
soutenir
enseigner partager et finalement ces
groupes socam de s'organiser s'organiser
en associations s'organisent et en clubs
sportifs en entreprise pour pouvoir
organiser ce changement pour voir créer
produire innover et ses organisations 5
l'ue elle même dans des systèmes
d'institutions à l'échelle d'un quartier
à l'échelle d'une ville à l'échelle d'un
pays ou à l'échelle d'une université ou
d'une école super de structurer ce
changement de le diriger de réguler nos
interactions et de les optimiser ou même
de protester donc à l'échelle de
l'individu vient nous sommes porteurs en
nous de cette capacité extraordinaire de
changement grâce aux autres par le biais
des autres seulement nous n'avons pas
toujours conscience de cet impact n'ont
pas toujours conscience de cette
capacité extraordinaire de changement
dont nous sommes porteurs
pourquoi et bien une hypothèse c'est que
la société dans cette conformation ci
pensant aller dans la bonne direction et
bien a finalement fini par nous
individualisé nous sommes centrés sur
nous mêmes et nous avons oublié que nous
avions cette capacité de faire société
justement et en tant qu'individu qui
voulons changer eh bien il est très
difficile d'avoir un impact réel ou en
tout cas significatif sur le monde parce
que nous sommes dépourvus de cette
capacité de changement dû à notre hyper
sociabilité et il ya un concept en
psychologie qui illustrent ces deux
scénarios ces deux extrêmes auxquelles
nous sommes confrontés en tant
qu'individu face à des changements d'une
telle ampleur à la crise écologique soit
appelle l'opus de contrôler un lot plus
de contrôles externes et bien nous
conduit à penser que quoi que l'on fasse
nous n'avons aucun contrôle sur le monde
le contrôle est extérieure à nous et
cette situation là on peut même nous
conduire à un phénomène qu'on appelle la
puissance acquise
l'impuissance acquis c'est d'être
tellement persuadé que nous n'avons
aucun impact sur le monde que nous
n'essayons même plus nous sommes
résignés
n'ayant même plus de changer al'inverse
le locus de contrôle interne nous pro du
conduit à penser que nous sommes
porteurs de tous le changement qu'à
nous-mêmes la société peut changer que
nous pouvons nous individus
individuellement faire changer le navire
de direction alors cela peut conduire à
une situation telle que l'illusion de
contrôler de penser qu'à nous mêmes et
bien nous pouvons tout changer ou alors
des situations qui sont plus frustrante
où on essaie chacun de faire des
sacrifices de changer à son échelle et
qu'on observe que les autres
individuellement ne font pas ce et cm
ces efforts là et que finalement la
somme des individualités ne fait pas un
mouvement collectif
et pour preuve c'est que des somme
d'individualités fait masse mais ne fait
pas un système d'organisation de
coopération et ne permet pas de
changement majeur
prenez la ville de lyon vous habitez
il est possible en tant qu'habitant de
cette ville de regarder la ville et de
la considérer comme extérieure à nous la
ville est un décor nous habitons cette
ville mais nous sommes simplement
figurants nous habitons nous allons
travail nous allons supermarchés et
c'est tout la ville s'organise
d'elle-même extérieurement à nous ne
sommes pas responsables
2 comment est-ce que lyon est organisée
al'inverse on peut considérer cette
ville comme un immense réseau un réseau
ou des choses bougent déjà des choses
secret ou des personnes mettent en
commun des compétences des ressources
pour faire vivre cette ville et que ces
changements et bien sont portés par des
individus dans la ville si l'on reprend
l'exercice que nous avons fait au début
ils ont identifié notre réseau social
nous avons trouvé notre place au sein du
collectif famille amis travail et les
personnes qui nous entourent et bien ce
réseau là à l'échelle de la société et
bien constitue une machine une machine
sociale dans lesquelles nous sommes un
rouage
nous sommes un rouage de société que
nous le voulions ou non
faisons partie de cette société nous
faisons société ne le voulions ou non et
ce n'est pas en ignorant la société que
on va ignorer ce qu'elle est en train de
produire ce n'est pas en ignorant la
politique que la produits politiques
cessent de s'exercer
ce n'est pas en ignorant le
réchauffement climatique que le
changement réchauffement climatique
continue de s'exercer
ce n'est pas en ignorant que en tant que
société dont nous faisons partie
eh bien nous avons un impact néfaste sur
notre environnement qui cause tout un
tas de dommages et de conditions de vie
que cela va s'arrêter
mais pire que ça en tant qu'individu et
bien et en tant que rouages et bien nous
sommes des ouailles actifs
nous contribuons à ces sociétés dans sa
conformation actuelle nous enseignons
nous produisons nous sommes des rouages
actifs de cette société alors bien sûr
tous les rouages n'ont pas la même
taille et certains gros rouages essaie
de se coordonner de communiquer entre
eux pour figer cette machine dans la
conformation qui les arrange
mais tous les rouages sont capables de
communiquer de partager des
connaissances de se coordonner de
s'organiser et nous mêmes pouvons nous
organiser pour faire petit à petit
changer cette machine nous sommes
capables de convaincre les autres de
porter des actions communes collective
tourner vers un but pour faire en sorte
que en tant que rouages et bien nous
tournions un rouage seule ne pourra pas
faire de changements majeurs mais pas
compte des rouages qui sans qui
s'imbriquent les uns des autres et
qu'ils essaient d'aller en direction
commune est bien pour mon petit à petit
faire changer cette société là à lyon et
bien il y a déjà tout un tas
d'initiatives d'actions collectives qui
sont en train de se faire actuellement
sur cette carte vous voyez plus d'une
centaine 17
yves d'actions ou des personnes se sont
mis ensemble ont mis à profit leurs
compétences leur sensibilité et leur
expérience pour accomplir des buts à des
échelles locales ce soit des bus de
tournée vers l'écologie vers l'éducation
vers la citoyenneté
ces personnes essaient d'aller dans une
direction commune et cette direction
commune c'est une société qui est plus
solidaire une société qui est plus
soutenable plus durable et ses petites
actions et bien sont en train de changer
petit à petit la société dans laquelle
nous sommes finalement en tant qu'humain
nous sommes porteurs de cette hyper
sociabilité nous sommes porteurs de
cette capacité de changement
nous sommes capables d'échanger des
connaissances mais aussi de pouvoir
tirer profit des connaissances qui ont
été accumulées jusqu'à lors internet est
une immense richesse de ce point de vue
là et d'ailleurs elle est une richesse
pour me connecter les uns aux autres
nous avons déjà la possibilité de
communiquer et de nous orienter ensemble
dans une direction commune dans un but
commun ce but nous le connaissons c'est
plus de sobriété énergétique
c'est un plus grande entre âge sur les
télés ancrage sur les territoires c'est
une mise en commun des moyens de
production de transport de consommation
exceptionnellement l'émergence de
sociétés qui sont solidaires de
communautés qui sont résiliente
il n'en tient qu'à nous donc de
s'organiser pour aller dans cette
direction de s'organiser en mettant au
sens de la solidarité pour sortir des
personnes leur isolement pour que ces
différentes expériences puisse être mise
à profit pour ensemble porter une action
collective dans une perspective
d'ouverture et de partage
parce que les erreurs ou les échecs de
certaines de ces actions pourront être
des enseignements pour d'autres et les
succès d'autres actions pourront faire
modèle et se propageait afin que ces
signaux faibles que l'on observe
actuellement devienne un signal fort et
que notre société change de direction
merci
[Applaudissements]